we were talking about what we would
comparatively be best in in an eating
contest in other words if your life
depended on an eating contest what food
would you pick um you mean what food
could I eat the most up or what food
what I love to eat the most both but the
first one specifically which is if
you're an eating contest against ten
random people and the only way you would
live is if you ate more than the other
nine what food would you pick because
you believe you can eat more of it than
the other nine people I think either
ears of corn or glazed doughnuts from
krispy kreme Wow although later my one
weight because I once I once ate 11 of
those does that is that a lot no I I
mean it might not even be a lot but but
here's not yeah but here's the thing
here's the thing Peter I think there's a
lot of people that can eat Krispy Kreme
a lot of Krispy Kremes don't you yeah
they're very light in in kind of Aries
so maybe 11 of those are not good but I
think I could eat a dozen ears of corn
which I I mean I've eaten six or seven
of them at once they seem to be a little
bit more filling than a Krispy Kreme
well I've been with you when you ate
possibly the best ear of corn you've
ever had at the lehigh valley ironpigs
stadium remember that i love the
ironpigs they what they do is they have
the they have the corn out in right
field now I don't know that this is
maybe four years ago that I was there
but they they had corn they had roasted
corn at right field and uh i believe
loss isn't that the cake this has to be
more than four years ago wasn't that the
day that Pedro Martinez pitched in
Allentown or Bethlehem forever correct
Allentown and after
and i were there together as by like
seven years ago at this point yeah I you
know hey look I mean there's a lot of
things that I could eat your hit me with
that real quick uh no I like that inches
yeah I like here's a corn it I mean I
because when I was a kid uh I would
always like grab as many years as I
could in my house my mother would would
uh would like boil a dozen and we have
six people at the table and I would
always try to get a third one I mean I
was always one of those little connivers
at the dinner table when you do the
training camp tour every August what's
your favorite City to go to from a food
perspective what do you most look
forward to like man I can't wait to go
there because I'm gonna this this and
that I try to like Pittsford New York
they have a place called the pittsford
that's where the buffalo bills right
outside of Rochester our Rochester yeah
yeah it's about an hour east of Buffalo
maybe an hour and 20 minutes and they
have a place called the pits dairy barn
where they have one of the great
culinary delights of my life which is a
black raspberry milkshake I look forward
to that I always like to go to to do the
bangles because I lived there for five
years and I love Cincinnati chili so
I'll either go to skyline or gold star
and get a four-way and then um you know
there's a there's a there's a couple of
pizza places in Seattle that have
fantastic thin crust pizza right
downtown that I really liked a lot and
so those are probably off the top of my
head three of the places i really like
to go to well speaking of cities
obviously the major topic at the NFL
owners quickie meetings whatever they
call these may mediums is picking the
Super Bowl cities you know based on what
you reported at the mmqb or guests I
should say and
p folks like Ian Rapoport of nfl.com as
well and if they'll network seems like
there's sort of a consensus that it's
going to be Atlanta South Florida and LA
I mean it's just going to be
rubber-stamped today well the read all
three of those make a lot of sense i
mean the first year New Orleans is
probably the other prime contender but
uh I just I don't think I don't sense a
lot of momentum even though i think the
league likes confidence and would like
doing a favor I just think they've given
new orleans north at so many games and
you know atlanta build a new stadium and
it would have been 19 years between
super bowls for Atlanta so I think
they're they're more inclined in the
second year of the Falcons new stadium
to sort of cap the second year with a
super bowl the the the next season I
think in an ideal world Roger Goodell
would want to give the Super Bowl to Los
Angeles because it's the 100-year the
100 season of professional football
capping the 2019 season in February 2008
but i think the rams feel like listen
we're just not going to be we're not
positive we're going to be ready how to
put on an event like that it'll be after
their first year they don't know if
everything on that campus is going to be
open and up to speed yet so by that time
Stephen Roswell's ten about 350 million
dollars in new refurbishments at the
dolphin stadium in South Florida so I
think that that probability is lightly
and then to kick off pro football second
century my gut feeling is they would
give it to Los Angeles the game in
February 2021 Super Bowl 55 talking with
peter king of the mmqb calm an
unbelievable sight there's a lot of
great long-form NFL stuff he's also on
NBC's football night in America Peter I
saw you tweeted yet
today about this story from ESPN's
outside the lines regarding a
congressional report indicating that the
NFL wagered an improper campaign to
influence a government study I guess my
only question here Peter is if you're
the NFL and you know all this stuff's
out there and you know the movie
concussion you go all the way back to
the NFL's track record in this regard
why would you any NFL obviously says
they did nothing wrong Peter they went
through the proper channels etc etc I
guess I don't understand why you're the
NFL why you would even take a chance
that someone could think that you're
trying to improperly influenced the
research like shouldn't they just be
beyond reproach at this point I I mean I
share I fear this opinion with you
basically the person at the center of
this sort of firestorm is a guy named
Robert stern who is a longtime
researcher in two concussions very very
intelligent guy at Boston University and
you know he sided with sort of the the
NFL considers the Renegades the
concussion lawsuit we'ii sided with a
bunch of those refuse to sign on former
players who refuse to sign on and allow
this concussion lawsuit to go through so
that former players can start getting
their money from this and so the NFL has
been at odds with Robert stern and when
the when this study was going they saw
it was going to be run by Robert stern
well they voiced their displeasure with
this I talked to Frank pallone the
congressman from New Jersey yesterday
about this and he said essentially this
simply isn't done you you if you give
money to fund a study you have to let
the study be done under the purview of
the National Institutes of Health and
the NFL according to cologne sought
interfere with that now our Jenny
mirantis is on-site today at the the NFL
meetings and as we're about to run a
story in which he said it's not that
simple there's there's a lot of there's
a lot of asterisks to that well there's
no question that the NFL wasn't happy
with stern there are some other factors
to this but still Ross I echo what you
say once you give money to fund a study
in my opinion you have to just stand
back and let the no matter what what
form the study is going to take if this
is a national organization or respected
governmental organization what they let
that organization do its job and the NFL
didn't do that in this case yeah and I
just thinking you know given everything
that's happened previously you can't
even take the chance that people would
think that yeah the optics are terrible
the optics are just are awful in this
without regardless of what the facts are
without question Peter always appreciate
the time thanks so much for hopping
aboard okay all the best take care of
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience